hey guys today it is june 30 my name is
jess mcdonald and you're watching games
but news the first wave of steam
hardware pre-orders is now done and
dusted so if you had your eye on picking
up valves fancy hardware early you'll
now have to wait until november 10
pre-ordering enabled gamers to pick up
their hardware a month early and
included the alienware steam machines
steam link and steam controllers for the
uninitiated the same link is a small $50
device that plugs into your TV and
allows you to stream Steam games from
Nexus think you see the steam controller
is valve solutions or PC gaming on your
couch and features to track pads which
can either replace your mouse influence
or act as more of a traditional
controller if you did happen to get a
pre-order in your hardware will be
available on October 16 non early bird
launch hardware is still able to be
pre-ordered through seen the last of us
to is likely on its way according to
voice actor Nolan North who name drops
the sequel to the critically acclaimed
game at metricon when asked whether
North would be working on any subsequent
Naughty Dog projects after uncharted 4
he replied Pannell uncharted 4 is the
last one I know they're doing the last
of us too but my character in The Last
of Us untimely demise it might be too
soon to get excited though since Joel
voice actor Troy Baker has said he knows
nothing about a sequel to The Last of Us
Baker has commented quote I don't know
if we're going to do another one or not
if we do I trust Neil druckmann free to
director and Bruce Straley gain director
and everyone at Naughty Dog to tell a
story that needs to be told currently
druckmann and straley are working on
for regardless of who you believe it's
not a particularly far-fetched idea that
a game which sold and rated extremely
well would be considered for the sequel
treatment finally for those of you still
playing GTA 5 more ill-gotten gains DLC
is on its way the free update ill-gotten
gains part 2 is set to land on consoles
and PC next week on july eight much like
its predecessor this update will include
all manner of high-end vehicles
over-the-top attire and just generally
expensive fancy crap the update will
also bring the previously pc exclusive
radio station entitled the lab to
consoles rockstar have released a number
of images to give you an idea of the
sorts of content you can get your hands
on let me know down in that comment box
what you would want out of a Last of Us
sequel you can hedge against what we've
got stories on Australia banning a whole
lot of games and the ps4 dominating in
Europe that is everything I've got for
you today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I'll catch you same
time tomorrow